name review me review welcome back to
America's the world's favorite show man
review mop it up everybody we're back
that's right give it a clock Kevin
around what just meme review since I've
been away of course there's been some
air there's been an empty void there's
been means that have not been reviewed
why how am I supposed to know what to
think about memes if Pierre depay hasn't
reviewed that man hello internet good
thing all the memes this week has been
[ __ ] first me what is the greatest
comeback of all the time when someone
hits you with a stinger and you just
know you have to come up with something
really good to really get them tobacco's
just the ultimate strongest comeback
that will send that back to the medieval
ages your mom gay that's right your mom
gay it's the greatest comeback of all
time there is nothing you can do if you
get hit by a your mom let's review some
memes of your mom game be my Valentine
your mom Gail oh oh my heart bleeds for
this man poor thing I assume you're mr.
gay your mom got him good
that's how you talk to women listen and
learn your mom vs. big gay a nice little
little fighting me who would win a
well-thought-out could structured
argument with very multiple valid points
your mom again that's right it doesn't
matter what they said if your mom is gay
is saying hey I don't look at me like
that I'm not the one that makes the
rules here's the aftermath of someone
hit by the your mom gay
it stinks it's it hurts just for me to
look at this is painful your mom it's
even gay you're up come on
but slight cheer your mom gave poor bus
like chair he didn't deserve that but
some say as painful as your mom gave me
mitts to be hit by some say that there
is one only one force that can match its
power your mom gay no you know you
potentially the match of your mom k if
you are having an intellectual fight
with another being and you get hit by
your mom gay the only thing the only
thing worth fighting back with is no you
know you or detective dicta if someone
hits you back with an O you I got you
your mom and dad gave to gether it
misses to all the globally starts
watching your mom gay I know what you're
thinking hey PI era
my mom is gay and that's not funny don't
worry don't worry of course this is just
a big coincidence
haha gay doesn't mean gay it means gross
Bechtold action to women it's an acronym
your mom gave me it's a fantastic
phenomenal meme it's not just a mean but
a power statement it's a Power Move to
inflict upon your worst enemy but only
the worst cuz you don't want to overdo
the damage that might be caused it's a
solid name that gets a three give it a
three it gets a number three it's worse
than applause I think at least maybe
I'll give it a sex it's a six now good
job good job your mom gave me you did it
what do you guys think let me know in
the comments I will 100% read all of
them they better not say your mom my mom
is not gay no you know you next a
question that we've all asked ourselves
since the beginning of mankind since
when used to live in cage and scribble
up one walls before we invented
civilization helicopters and buggy gems
there was one question that was yet to
be answered where is your pee story
everyone is asking this question is pee
stored in the balls scientists have been
trying to figure out this incredible
phenomena for a very long time and
there's many different theories and
assumptions here we have Barack Obama
saying P is stored in the dick that's
why it's called penis Chris of the pee
[Music]
make sense if we store pee in the balls
why do girls store them in them titties
to girls
Mike Tyson famous scientist says P is
stored in the heart I mean I don't
understand where else it could possibly
be Mike Tyson now you're just being
silly Yoda says P is stored in two balls
Neil deGrasse Tyson says peanuts are
called peanuts because P is stored in
the nuts he makes an excellent point
I think this is the right theory Thank
You Neil deGrasse Tyson for your
contribution to the science community
finally we know how to store be there
for chicks do not pee for where would
they store it that's right women don't
pee
everyone knows this it's a common fact
it's the Mandela effect where everyone
believes one thing but the truth is
actually completely different the pee is
in fact stored in the balls everyone
knows this please spread this message
across the internet so we can finally
stop the debate and move past two more
important parts of science like it's the
earth flat we're still working on that
one but in the meantime there's some
haters of course and the P is stored in
the balls community there's the critics
saying if P is stored in the balls then
why don't they shrink when we pee this
can easily be explained but it will take
too long and I don't have time for pity
intellectuals like yourself why are
you're all so big me need to pee I think
it's time to move on from this week next
I forgot to rape this me my god this is
a fantastic meme probably the best meme
that we've ever had it's getting a one
it's such a good me just kidding it gets
us sex six point
five point four next ah Black Panther is
out in the cinema and people are excited
so am i it's looking great I can't wait
to watch it people have a lot of
opinions about the movie bla bla bla
stupid limp tardes try to politicize the
movie hang stupid stupid lib tarts makes
me angry if you give Black Panther a bad
review you are racist I don't care I
don't care I don't care he's right he's
right I'm not disputing this there's a
lot of political claims about the film
for example this old man's purposeless
rolling Black Panther is another perfect
example of white people putting their
noses in places it doesn't belong and I
agree 100% why this man was in this film
it makes me so angry if you're white and
you don't go see Black Panther at the
midnight release you are racist and if
you're white and you do go see Black
Panther at the minute release then
you're racist because you're taking up a
seat of a black person come on come on
what do you thinking so I carefully did
not buy Black Panther tickets for the
opening weekend because I didn't want to
be the right person looking black
theater what's the appropriate date for
me to buy ticket this next weekend okay
can I please go see the movie now please
the right answer of course is two weeks
you have to wait two weeks there was a
picture of the prank a private viewing
from Black Panther where people did the
Black Power sign living in the screen
empty big mistake big no-no that's not
gonna fly so people added in other
beautiful images as a meme here we have
Logan boy oh wow
Black Panther is looking great can't
wait to watch it finally a progressive
film is that markiplier I didn't know he
was in the Black Panther film oh the new
Black Panther he only know Spiderman was
in it that's amazing I'm so happy now
why wouldn't you be excited about a suit
amande movie there's only been 18 of
them from marvel itself I don't
understand why anyone would not be
excited about this film the Black
Panther me was not even to me I don't
know why I added it in it gets a 10 out
of 10 it's one of the greatest memes I
have ever seen in my life
do we have time for bonus meme yes we do
fantastic upon you friend we have time
for boners me here we go
girl how much do you love me boy one
girl oh my god you're so mean I hate you
girl commit suicide boy visits girls
grave boy million like if you cried
leave a like right now because I know
your range because so am i this is so
sad can we hit fifty legs check out
another meme review right here click on
it a good time there's more memes to
explore hopefully next week
won't be so so great as this one because
this will never be better than this one
squat fam out